If I haven't been so good at taking my supplements for a few months, should I just get back
on them or should I do another cheek swab test?
Probably if you still have the supplements, let's say you haven't taken them for three
months because you're feeling really good and you're really falling off the wagon.
And then I got this, you feel convicted for some reason or you get a symptom that reminds
you of that, you know, I can't ignore this and you decide to get back on the wagon.
If you still have the supplements, start taking them right away, but it would probably
be wise to do another cheek swab test because things could change if you haven't been
on them for three months.
So if you had supplements, get right back on them again, but send in a cheek swab and we'll
check and tweak your protocol.
And you know, we also want to be cognizant of, did you stop taking them because you just
were tired of taking supplements or you stopped taking them because you're just feeling great,
you're not really good at the discipline of taking supplements like me.
There's reasons why we stopped doing things, so we want to know that too.
So if it's like, I stopped taking them because I just can't, I just can't, or they will
try to, you know, get the most important ones so you're at a more minimal program.
That you can stay on, you know, so we want you to be on the things that are going to be the
most cancer killing that that are going to be the best for you that you are, that you can stay
on. No, since putting it in the perfect program, somebody and they just won't do it.
I've done that over the years.
I've had people that have done the cheek swab test, paid for our whole program, started with us,
said to the regimen, and they never even bought anything.
They never did anything. I don't get it.
But everybody has their reasons.
So I would like that communication back of why maybe the reason is, I just, I can't swallow
anything. I'm not feeling good. I can't eat anything. I can't certainly not going to be able to swallow
supplements. So I'm not going to buy any of those.
Whether we could try to do switching around a test for some more liquid approach or a powdered
approach where you could make a smoothie, I just would like that feedback so that we could be
the best clinic for you. So it's, this is about you. So I don't want you to feel, anybody to feel
like to put this out. This is about you. We're here to serve you. So we need the feedback. We need
honest feedback. It's like, I just can't take all these. I need, we get that feedback a lot.
And funny, it's sometimes we get that feedback. I don't want to take all these supplements
anyway. I can cut back on supplements. And I look, send me everything you're taking. Like,
I ask all of you guys. And sometimes they're taking like 12 different supplements. And I never even
recommend it. So you know, you guys got to, you know, look at this big picture too. And we just need
to have that communication and have a discussion of what's going to be the best way for you to stay
on a protocol that is going to be beneficial for you. So keep that in mind as well.